listening to a film courage with
and carry more
he'll a talk radio
and when you say that someone looks
ready what's that vibe that someone
gives off when they walk into a room
because you've written about that before
that you're kind of your vibe your aura
whatever you want to call it announces
who you are before you you even open
your mouth what is that vibe that the
actor gives off that they're ready I
think it's more that they are not giving
off the stench of desperation it's sort
of what it's like dating you know you
know the date the date with the person
who just kind of leans in a little too
much and who's just a little too eager
and you're like man it's not going to
happen you know it's and could have
everything going for him but if it's if
it's just he's too eager you kind of
feel uncomfortable on his behalf it's a
lot like that especially this comes back
to the having the survival job that
doesn't beat you down because if you
show up to an audition feeling like I
have to book this because if I don't I
can't pay rent we feel that and we feel
anxious for you remember we're all
sensitive craters everybody who's in
this industry we're all artists were all
creatives even if our job is to
negotiate major deals we still have that
side of us that is creative or we
wouldn't be drawn to this industry and
so because of that we're very sensitive
to those vibes and when somebody walks
into the room feeling hungry and
desperate and needy for it we may not
even understand that that's where that's
coming from but we just feel this sense
of man there's tension there's something
there that is making me uncomfortable
and instead you need to make us feel
like hey don't worry I got this let me
show you how I act and then by us
feeling that you have that confidence
and don't mistake confidence for being
cocky but when you come in with that
confidence and the ability to then show
us the work and make us comfortable that
you got it covered then you feel like a
solution to a problem which is all
casting is